I'm the role of the black community
borders to probably consider in refer to
all matters referred to us by the
Invercargill City Council maintain an
overview of the services provided by
them to cargill City Council prepare an
end submission on expenditure and
probably an annual submissions on abaca
go long-term plan and also the
environment Southland long-term plan
also we get involved with community
groups liaise with them and and have a
good working relationship with them but
probably most of all is the probably act
and the best interests of the bluff
community and that's what we're all
about we are from bluffing and we know
what's good for bluff and what isn't
good for blood
well Bluffs got two cemeteries we got
the one at at greenpoint cemetery it's
on the way into bluff and we also got
the old bluff symmetry which is the top
of lagan street there was a lot of
microcarpa sand pine trees overhanging
us some of the graves and some of the
branches are falling off and causing
some damage and because of the trees
here they couldn't get them and behind
those graves and clear the land between
the graves and trees so the Invercargill
City Council have now cut down all the
trees cleared it and just looking at the
process of planning some natives along
that western edge we believe we've
achieved a lot the shell we've managed
to have the fences restained along the
main street opposite the surface center
we have worked with in vacaville City
Council and pushing her transit Musil
ined to get the roads upgraded coming
into bluff that has that project will be
undertaken this the summer we believe
and also we have put in submission and
the long term plan to have sterling
Pointe finished with footpaths put
around near for the pedestrians and that
was approved with the long term plan and
that work will be carried out the sum
the season as well so we encourage all
residents that you know it's all
voluntary work with these community
groups in and without volunteers that
they wouldn't the things that are
happening around bluff wouldn't happen
and we encourage people to find out of
what their interests are and if one of
the community groups is one of your
interests is just contact the
chairperson of that group will contact
myself we're an open book and that's
what it's all about with them bluff with
with air to work for bluff and make
buffer be at a place to live in well the
wrong with bluff promotions is to
promote the bluff brand Bluff as a place
to visit a place to live we work with
local businesses and community
organizations and events to make sure
that they're promoted that they get
media coverage and that people see
bluffers an attractive place love
promotions are not contracted to anyone
where
committee we do have a funding
arrangement through the bluff community
board with the City Council well we've
been involved in a lot of events this
year the bluff hill climbers the first
event in the Burt Munro challenge that
happens every year on the last Thursday
in November and Bluff promotion stages
that in association with the south on
motorcycle club well other projects were
working on at the moment people may have
noticed the picnic tables along the
foreshore road and the green area
opposite the service center those have
been placed there by bluff promotions
the up and over bluff Hill grumped which
is famous in Southland it's a fun run a
lot of people use it as a training event
for the Kepler challenge